Speaker 1: I want to start today with what
is happening in Cuba, which is both horrifying
and it's fascinating, it's politically relevant.
And of course, we're all globally, as we'll
talk about in a moment, every country in some
way dealing with not just coronavirus generally,
but also this resurgence of the virus, despite
vaccinations starting to roll out because
of the very contagious Delta variant.
All of this relates to what's going on in
Cuba.
So let's start there.
A very good article in the BBC explaining,
generally speaking, what's happening in Cuba
right now.
If you've not been following it, there are
essentially three issues here that are leading
to massive protests in Cuba.
First is, as is written here, the coronavirus
crisis.
The protests, the BBC writes, appear to be
the result of societal exhaustion stemming
from acute economic and health crises.
The pandemic and economic measures taken by
the government have made life in Cuba increasingly
difficult.
The pen, the island which had kept the pandemic
under control in twenty twenty, has seen infections
explode in recent week weeks.
We'll look at those numbers momentarily.
But records in terms of daily infections,
in terms of deaths, the health care system
on the brink of collapse, that is one piece
of it.
And the hashtag S.O.S Cuba has been trending
on Twitter.
This is one of the you know, one of the areas
that we've seen open slightly in Cuba is that
of Internet access.
And now that leading to the S.O.S Cuba hashtag,
which the government is not thrilled with.
And we will talk about that in a moment.
Number two, the economic situation.
Tourism is one of the main engines for the
Cuban economy, almost completely paralyzed
as a result of the coronavirus pandemic.
In addition, Cuba is seeing inflation, blackouts,
food shortages, as well as shortages of medicine
and basic products.
Those aren't new issues, but they have been
particularly worse lately.
At the beginning of the year, the government
proposed a new package of economic reforms
that while increasing wages triggered a spike
in prices prices.
Economists such as Pavel Vidal from the Pontificator
have Indiana University of Caleigh and Columbia
estimate prices could rise between five hundred
and nine percent in the next few months.
Starting to look like my birth country of
Argentina from the standpoint of inflation.
And then number three, Internet access.
Before Sunday, the largest protest Cuba had
seen since the start of Castro's communist
revolution took place in August of 94.
Many Cubans had no idea what happened because
of lack of Internet access.
30 years on, the scenario is different.
Under the presidency of Raul Castro, Cuba
has liberalized, taking some liberalizing
steps which increased Internet connectivity.
And as I mentioned earlier, as a result of
that, Cubans have been using social networks
to express dissatisfaction with the government.
Mainly young people now have access to Facebook,
Twitter and Instagram.
And this platform was these platforms were
used to organize the protests.
So then we look at, well, what is the U.S.
perspective on this?
Because the US has had crippling sanctions
on Cuba for a very long time, sanctions that
while I am not a communist and I am against
the way that Cuba has operated with no open
elections for decades, despite promises made
during the 1950s and 60s, I'm completely against
that.
I also recognize the total hypocrisy of the
US saying, well, we can't tacitly endorse
the way Cuba is run and so we're putting sanctions
on them.
And yet we have the relationship we have with
Saudi Arabia and many other countries.
OK, so I've talked about that before.
Joe Biden yesterday during a press event bringing
up the Cuban protests and saying the US stands
with the people of Cuba.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: OK, folks, I want to start by recognizing
the remarkable protests that are taking place
in Cuba, the Cuban people demanding their
freedom from an authoritarian regime.
And I don't think we've seen anything like
this protest in a long, long time.
Of course, frankly, ever the United States
stands firmly with the people of Cuba as they
assert their universal rights and become the
government of Cuba to refrain from violence
or attempts to silence the voice of the people
of Cuba.
And we're also closely following the developments
in Haiti.
Speaker 1: So this is a complicated issue.
And anybody you know, you've got a lot of
very right wing Cubans in Florida, for example,
who love Trump and who are saying we need
to continue crushing the Cuban government
and punishing we're just punishing the people
if we do that.
On the other hand, we also have to recognize
that part of why things are the way they are
in Cuba is because of American policy towards
Cuba for decades.
And so anybody who wants to sort of pigeonhole
me on this issue and say, well, bit, but so,
David, are you for or against or what?
You know, we have to recognize that on the
one hand, the U.S. has had a major role in
keeping things worse in Cuba than they could
otherwise be.
We should be easing the sanctions that Trump
put in.
Remember that Barack Obama eased some sanctions.
Donald Trump came in and reinstituted a lot
of those sanctions.
And although Joe Biden is on the one hand
saying we're with the Cuban people, the very
sanctions that Joe Biden has not eased that
were put back in place by Donald Trump are
part of why things are so bad.
At the same time, I have been unquestionably
against the authoritarian regime in Cuba all
of this time.
But we must recognize that the U.S. is friendly
with many authoritarian regimes.
And so singling out Cuba has been a hypocrisy
for decades.
Obviously, my main concern is the Cuban people,
and these are massive and significant protests
because of the Internet access.
This may be that we're seeing the repression
from the police state of Cuba and we're getting
reports of, you know, officers on every corner
and everything you can imagine would go on
is going on at the same time.
We can't ignore the U.S. role in Cuba being
at least partially the way that it is now.
We'll see over the next 48 hours the direction
that the government response to the protests
is going
to take.